5 signs of zinc deficiency and how to
include more zinc in your diet brittle
nails that break very easily horizontal
grooves running across the fingernails
double white lines that go horizontally
across the nails weak hair that breaks
easily or diffuse hair loss and a
decreased sense of taste or smell
pumpkin seeds are one of the best
sources of zinc just 50 grams of pumpkin
seeds can provide more than 60 of daily
recommended dietary value of zinc
oysters are one of the richest sources
of zinc the zinc present in oysters is
highly bioavailable meaning it is easily
absorbed and utilized by the body meat
is an excellent source of zinc a 100
gram serving of raw ground beef provides
almost 50 of daily recommended value of
zinc mushrooms especially shiitake
mushrooms are also a very good source of
zinc 100 grams of cashews provide
approximately 5 milligrams of zinc which
accounts for about 45 of the recommended
daily intake for adults so load up on
that zinc and remember stay healthy and
stay curious